great intro
hey guys it is Thursday you're on its
grace and it's time for me to teach you
how to do something at the end of July
which is almost August which is almost
September which is when most of you are
going back to school what do you need
for going back to school just some extra
self-esteem that will inevitably be
crushed by the perils that our peer
pressure and social acceptance and
school supplies a lot of people create
vision boards which are collages of
things that they hope to obtain or
inspirational quotes or photos or
anything like that so today I'm going to
show you how you can turn your plain
stupid binder into a vision binder here
the supplies I have a glue stick Sharpie
markers scissors and some magazines to
cut out some inspirational photos and
words I got magazines to cover my two
favorite things in the entire world pop
culture and Western horseman let's do it
there's no method to this madness
it's basically an opportunity for you to
freely create anything that inspires you
or it doesn't make you feel bad I think
it's helpful to start with one center
focal piece I wonder I want them to be a
quote or a photo or picture I'm not sure
yet let me just see if there's something
that inspires me a taco found it now I'm
gonna cut that out they give you
stickers that you can apply to your
scissors to make them more interesting
people that do that I have a feeling
we'll never really be interesting tacos
gonna be a center of my piece also my
battery is running low oh no this is
disastrous I don't think I have a
charger with me Oh double disastrous go
ahead and do this hyper speed let's take
these on I'm gonna clue that I'm not
gonna research this here oh sheesh that
was a close one
okay my battery's gonna die it's weak to
do this as quick as possible yeah oh
there was a photo of Bruce Jenner on the
other side damn it
so far so good yeah I think I'm gonna
use the sharpies and write like an
insert
additional quote on this may find a
really good inspirational quote okay
here's the quote I chose from the window
to the walls to the sweat drop down my
balls dance like no one's watching
now it's gonna glue on some more
inspiring photos around the front of it
that really just like make me wanna be
the best version of myself here's a
family in my Western Horseman magazine I
don't know who they are what they do but
they seem great remember it does not do
perfect
here's we got so far they got a little
split up but that's okay I'm gonna make
it work now it looks like this guy is
thinking about the tacos he's clearly
the child stuck in the middle of this
love battle and he's just thinking about
tacos so always dream kid okay let's get
some more visuals and maybe some
powerful words okay guys almost done
this is like a really fun project to do
with your friends or by yourself tears
are a great way to decorate it and there
we have it there's my vision binder let
me explain a little bit to you so you
know I started with the taco and then
the broken family with the Sun dreaming
about a taco the phrase splash but down
here like always make a splash with your
butt this is a photo of Giuliana
Rancic's son and he was crying on the
red carpet because he was trying to get
a balloon but then I cut out the face of
Prince William son the Royal baby and I
put it over the balloon so it meant the
symbolism is like always reach for your
dreams like this child is not as good as
this child so it's like always reach to
be better this was a photo of Elle
Macpherson and a bikini I could have a
photo of a doll that has a hat does this
dopey on it and I put it over her face a
horse wearing a fly mask so I can't
really like to see anything and then the
horse is saying love is blind hashtag la
you can't really see if it's it's bread
because just that's delicious I have the
crotches of three Cowboys with their
hands in their pockets so it's like
always check your pocket Romney direct I
don't know who that is but it was the
name inside the western cowboy magazine
so gotta be good then I'm a photo of
honey boo boo just shoving cheetos in
her mouth like zero given then I have a
really inspiring quote that says I don't
think there's any better feeling in the
world than riding a good cow a horse a
good cow a horse last but not least I
have just some numbers here that could
be someone's phone number it's not mine
but I just thought like always remember
that like there is no real privacy so
there you go that's my vision binder I
hope this inspires you to make your own
vision binders and if you do don't
forget to tag
[Music]